now India's prime minister is due to
address a joint meeting of the U.S
Congress in a few hours but three house
Democrats say they'll boycott and
they're Andrew modi's address accusing
him of violating religious freedom in
India
President Joe Biden has already welcomed
Modi at the White House is being seen as
an attempt to improve relations despite
disagreements over Ukraine and human
rights
when our White House correspondent
Kimberly halcott joins us now Kimberly
uh what are we expecting from this then
yeah we can hear the band already
warming up for that arrival that is set
to take place in the next hour we can
expect that the India's prime minister
will be arriving on the south lawn of
the White House what we can expect is on
the heels of an intimate dinner with the
first lady as well as the U.S president
that India's prime minister will not
only be sitting down in the Oval Office
with Joe Biden but he will also be
addressing a joint session of the U.S
Congress and then later we'll be
enjoying a state dinner now we should
point out just to underscore how special
this is there's only one other world
leader the South Korean leader that has
been extended this special invitation by
the White House and that really
underscores how important this
relationship is to the White House and
the reason is really twofold first the
White House is concerned specifically
about how cozy India has become come
with Russia in recent months and so that
is one reason and the other is really
because of the concern about the ongoing
Global clash between autocracy and
democracy so those are really the two
issues that Joe Biden will be talking
about when he sits down with the Indian
Prime Minister in the Oval Office and
and that's because India has in recent
months abstained at the United Nations
with regard to really bringing Russia to
account for its invasion of Ukraine and
also there has been concern about
India's actions when it comes to freedom
of the press and also its ongoing
Crackdown against Muslims so there has
been some concern about this warm
embrace if you will that Joe Biden is
extending to the Indian leader in fact
there are 75 members of Joe Biden's own
Democratic party in both the house and
the Senate who say that the President
should not be doing this in fact they
sent a letter stating just that to Joe
Biden saying this is not something he
should do in fact it's a contradiction
of his own foreign policy that
underscores that human rights comes
first and so they're pushing him to
bring this up when he sits down in the
Oval Office and in fact there are going
to be three members of Congress who will
be boycotting the speech when Prime
Minister Modi addresses The Joint
session of Congress so there are going
to be a number of major announcements
that will be made during this meeting we
know that there will be some trades and
weapons deals that will be announced as
well as some Visa announcements that
will be made as well so we're watching
all of this it's going to be a very busy
day and it all kicks off at the top of
the hour busy day indeed Kimberly thanks
for that
Well modi's Visit comes as the countries
see closer ties especially military
cooperation the U.S wants to sell more
weapons to India's Armed Forces to
reduce their dependence on Russia Moscow
supplies 85 percent of India's military
hardware stronger ties with India will
also help the U.S counter China's
dominance in the indo-pacific region
the U.S is India's largest trading
partner with bilateral trade increasing
to a record 191 billion dollars last
year some Western companies have closed
their production lines in China and see
India as an alternative manufacturing
base
or staying with this now Brahma chalani
is a professor of strategic studies at
the center for policy research in New
Delhi and a former advisor to India's
National Security Council he joins us
live from New Delhi thanks for being
with us so overall then what do you
think is the significance of this
meeting for the future of India and how
it positions itself in the world
universities constitute one of the
world's fastest growing bilateral
relationships
Russia
bolster the Deep fractal Alliance
this is Raising concerns in America
about being caught in a double pencil
India Today is the world's fastest
growing media economy and booming U.S
experts to the huge to the huge Indian
market including weapon sales
reinforce India's importance to U.S
policy
Northeast was it by a fostering greater
closeness between the two powers
would prove pivotal in providing a
clearer direction to U.S India
cooperation
and what will the U.S be hoping to gain
from this then when you consider they
don't always see eye to eye do they for
example they're very different
approaches to Russia and China
well certainly they do not see eye to
eye on several issues including on
issues that are critical to India's
Regional interests for example
India does not agree with American
policy in Afghanistan Pakistan built
does not agree with American policy in
regard to sanctions on Myanmar on Iran
and also opposes the University of
sanctions against Bangladesh but the U.S
and India do have converging interests
on larger strategic issues what want is
stable balance of power in the
indo-pacific a stable balance of power
free of coercion and India's growing
economic and Military heft has made it
crucial to establishing such a stable
balance of power in Asia and The Wider
indo-pacific region
but not everyone let me forgive me but
not everyone is happy about modi's visit
are they I mean due to what they would
they would say is his poor record or
regarding the Muslim Community in India
for example
I think it's important to clarify him
matters
India is the world's largest democracy
even if an imperfect one every democracy
is a work in progress
but what stands out about India is that
it's as politically polarized as the
United States
think of that Trump presidency Just As
Trump was accused while in office of
being a wannabe dictator of undermining
U.S democracy and pursuing an
anti-muslim agenda similar Acquisitions
are being held against Modi by his
critics at home and abroad
it is important to remember that just as
American democracy survived from Indian
democracy is strong enough to check any
erosion in Democratic rights India has
the world's second largest Muslim
population and Muslims enjoy equal
rights and are proud citizens of India
anybody who visits India can see that
India remains as free a country as any
other established democracy in the world
make no mistake about that
okay we leave it there uh Brahma chalani
thanks very much indeed for your time
here on Al Jazeera